why you
L and you
CH and you try to make full L of
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
so as we get into our discussion about
Mr Sinister what we're going to find
here is that much like apocalypse
Sinister is usually always a hidden hand
he's usually always in the background
manipulating things and as we'll learn
with this video he's actually
manipulated a lot of different people's
lives Havoc Cyclops Jean Gray meline PRI
and wol Rain he's manipulated their
existence in such a way that it always
usually comes out to his benefit or to
some kind of plan that he's orchestrated
and this is the fundamental principle of
Mr Sinister rather than being someone
like Magneto who's always in the front
lines and engaging in the really gritty
work Sinister just hides he usually just
stays back but he always appears at some
of the more interesting times now what
we're going to see with this video is
that we're going to start off with the
initial appearance of Mr Sinister in
Marvel Comics and then as we progress
we're going to more or less fly through
a few things because again Sinister just
kind of pops up provides some
information and then goes away but once
we actually get to the Further
Adventures of Cyclops and Phoenix we'll
learn the basis behind sinister's
existence why it was that he's created
as well as his obsession with both
Cyclops and Jean Gray and then we'll
segue back into and I guess do this big
circle where we revolve or I guess uh
move ourselves back to when it was that
he had first appeared and why now
Sinister first appeared in Uncanny X-Men
Issue Number 220
and again this is almost immediately
after the events of the mutant Massacre
now because we've talked about the
mutant massacre in a few videos before
we're not really going to go that
in-depth into it but what we had seen is
that with the end of the mutant Massacre
psylock had scanned the mind of
sabertooth and when she did she had seen
some hidden benefactor someone shrouded
in darkness that she couldn't quite make
out and this was more or less Chris
Claremont telling us that there's some
Hidden Hand very similar to the way
apocalypse had first appeared under Luis
Simonson now with issue number 221 we
learned that Sinister is actually the
guy that orchestrated the entire mutant
Massacre event he's the one that set the
event in motion now his motivations for
doing this again was because of the fact
that uh he had looked at the morlocks
and believed that there was perhaps some
uh involvement of himself within the
creation of the morlocks of course we
know that this was the result of dark
beasts manipulating mutants in this time
and creating the morlocks due to the
fact that the dark Beast had more or
less been a student of Mr Sinister in
the Age of Apocalypse storyline but with
the mutant Massacre event and with this
story what we had seen was that Sinister
has instructed the Marauders his
henchmen to attempt to kill meline prior
a second time now this is when we begin
to see things intertwining and we begin
to see all these different stories and
different groups meeting one another at
these Crossroads if you recall our
discussion about the formation of
xfactor we had talked about how there
came a point whereby when xfactor was
formed that Cyclops had abandoned both
meline prior and his infant son there
came a point when Cyclops went back to
try to find meline prior and his son
again but of course they were gone now
it was shown to us that mine prior
seemed to have been killed and that his
infant son had simply just vanished we
didn't know where he went and what we
learn with this story is that it was
actually the Marauders that had
attempted and presumably been successful
in killing meline prior and had
kidnapped the infant son of Cyclops and
taken him to Mr Sinister now what is
revealed to us in this story as well is
that meline PRI had actually survived
that meline PRI had ended up in a
hospital but that again Cyclops wasn't
really aware of this Cyclops didn't
really know now from here we transition
to uh to the fall of mutants and with
the fall of mutants storyline of course
again the event that led up to the
formation of Excalibur we had seen that
mine prior had presumably actually been
killed alongside the other X-Men but of
course again as we had seen the X-Men
hadn't been killed they had simply just
been removed from all forms of
observation with the exception of the
naked eye and so unless anyone who
recognized the X-Men had seen them they
would have been presumed dead by
virtually anyone and so this was when
Sinister had uh had more or less assumed
that meline prior that the situation had
been taken care of now again at this
point we don't know why it was that he
had gone after meline PRI in the first
place but what we see is that meline PRI
launches something thing called The
Inferno event and mine prior returns as
the goblin Queen She of course had
struck a bargain with some demons in
limbo and so on and of course that goes
into the Inferno event proper but the
idea here is that she's returned to
looking for her uh looking for her
infant son and of course she knows that
uh that Mr Sinister has her child now
what this does is this Segways into
uncanny xman issue number 241 as part of
The Inferno event and as part of this
Inferno event Sinister reveals to meline
Prior that again he had been
manipulating her entire existence and
this is actually a really interesting
story because what it does it gives us a
lot of insight into the existence of
meline Prior as well as the involvement
of sinister within the lives of both
Cyclops and Jean Gray what Sinister
tells us is that meline prior had been a
clone of Gan gray that uh when Gan gray
had taken on the Phoenix force and then
become the dark Phoenix which resulted
in uh her presumed death on the moon
that Sinister had a problem and the
problem was without Jean Gray there's no
way for him to create this uh more or
less Uber mutant that could uh serve
whatever purpose it was that he was
looking for it to serve and so what he
did is he took some genetic material of
Jean Gray and he had cloned her and made
meline PRI out of that clone but when
meline PRI had been created when she had
reached her maturity she hadn't
developed any Mutant powers and so it
would have been impossible for him to
actually pass her off as Jean Gray but
the other half of this equation is that
when genan gray had died or presumably
been killed that the Phoenix Force had
sparked life inside of meline Prior now
of course it doesn't mean that melin
prior had developed any abilities it
just simply means the Phoenix Force had
provided her with just enough to
actually give her character some life
and so this is when Sinister came up
with the idea of initiating contact
between meline prior and cyclops knowing
that as soon as Cyclops had seen mine
prior he would immediately fall in love
with her because he would be reminded of
Jean Gray and over the course of this
situation Sinister played things out and
manipulated the two of them in such a
way that they would produce a child
which led to Sinister going after meline
PRI and the child now the reason why
Sinister had pursued and attempted to
kill meline PRI was as he explains
mateline prior of course being the clone
of Gan gray could not exist while Gan
gray was alive when it was revealed that
Gan gray was alive and the reason is
because Jean Gray is a telepath and with
Jean Gray being a telepath she would
have immediately scanned the mind of
mine when she saw her as a direct clone
of herself and learned about the
existence of sinister and so Sinister
sent the Marauders after mine PRI to
attempt to remove her from the equation
but Sinister had believed this problem
had been taken care of when meline prior
had supposedly been killed alongside the
other X-Men now from here we pick up
with xfactor issue number 39 and with
xfactor issue number 39 meline prior has
more or less been removed from the
equation but what he does what Sinister
does is gives us some insight into his
involvement his fascination with both
Cyclops and havoc in that he has
apparently been manipulating their
entire lives since they were both
children in an orphanage in Nebraska he
had been experimenting on them
conducting uh various tests on them and
so for so on and so forth and had more
or less been shaping their lives playing
and playing their lives out and
monitoring them as they've progressed
into adulthood now at this point we
transitioned to Cable issue number six
and of course cable issue number six is
after the events of the Executioner song
crossover whereby Strife the future
clone of cable had traveled into the
past in an attempt to take revenge on
both Jean Gray and Scott Summers as well
as try to kill professor Charles Xavier
now at this point in time cable believed
that he was the clone of strife that he
was the uh he was the copy but what
Sinister reveals to Cable in issue
number six is that cable is actually the
original and that Strife is the Clone
now during this process Sinister also
awakens the uh I I guess the element or
the remains of strife's I guess mind
within Cable's own mind and in turn
Strife takes over the mind of cable and
when he does he of course again goes on
a war path against the X-Men now at this
point we transition to Cable annual uh
issue I guess 1999 and with cable annual
1999 Sinister expands a little more on
what it was that he had told Cable in
issue number six in issue number six all
he had told cable was that he was the
real son of meline Prior and cops and
The Strife was the Clone in cable annual
1999 Sinister tells cable that the whole
reason for him to have been created the
whole reason why he was made is because
Sinister wanted someone that had
hitherto unchallenged abilities someone
that could stand toe-to-toe and most
likely overpower apocalypse and Destroy
apocalypse entirely and so for cable
this is an incredible Revelation this is
an unbelievable Revelation but of course
cable despite the fact that Sinister
extends his hand hand and ask cable to
step into the role that had previously
been created for him cable of course
turns it down refuses to side with
Sinister and goes about trying to reform
his group now at this point we
transition to the to the I guess the
origin stories to the history of uh of
of sinister with the stories of Further
Adventures of Cyclops and Jean now with
this story there was a lot going on
there was quite a bit taking place there
was the involvement of Apocalypse of Mr
Sinister of Jean Gray and got Summers
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to rush through this a little bit
but we're going to try to make it make
sense just because it's a four-part
series and we can make an entire video
in and of itself focusing strictly on
the background of Nathaniel Essex or Mr
Sinister what we learn in this story is
that Nathaniel Essex or Mr sinister's
son had previously passed away before
the story had started and as a result
Sinister had become obsessed with the
idea of not only human evolution but the
possibility of bringing his son back to
life now it's not explicitly stated to
us that his desire is to bring his son
back but all that's really given to us
is this obsession with with genetics
this obsession with human evolution and
in fact Nathaniel Essex is the first one
to apparently come across the idea that
human beings will at some point evolve
to a place where they will uh I guess
overtake normal Humanity in terms of
their prowess meaning that mutants will
someday arrive in the uh in on the
planet Earth and so for him the idea is
how would this happen how is this going
to take place what he does is he goes to
the Royal Society which is the Society
of the uh I guess the top Minds in
Britain at the time of scientists and of
course he presents his idea to them
saying that Charles Darwin was on the
first steps he was taking baby steps
into what would become a much bigger
thing but the mistake that he makes is
he reveals to them what he perceives to
be an example of a mutant later on when
he has more or less a Frankenstein
figure an individual that's been pieced
together with different body parts now
of course this being doesn't have life
it's simply just what he perceives to be
a caricature of uh the most likely
result of mutant manipulation or mutant
existence of course the Royal Society at
the time was not ready to see this and
they shun Nathaniel Essex and throw him
out and so as a result Nathaniel Essex
who's somewhat down on his luck at this
particular point in time who has not
really become as strange to his wife but
certainly began to move away from her of
course goes to a pub to drown his
sorrows in alcohol along the way he
comes across a group who refer to
themselves as Marauders and what this
group has done as it is it has gone
about and captured what would be
considered I guess by uh any real
standard the early version of the
morlocks that is to say individuals who
are either physically deformed or
somehow mentally touched and the mor I'm
sorry the Marauders argue that this is a
service they're doing to London that the
London Police and London Society don't
have to worry about this because they're
basically keeping these people shunted
away their initial intention is to
capture Sinister to capture Nathaniel
Essex due to the fact that he's anemic
he's very pale and for them this is a
little strange but what Nathaniel Essex
does is he offers them an opportunity he
tells them that if they decide to work
for him basically to uh bring him
individuals whom they've captured then
of course he'll pay him very well for
their work and so the Marauders uh this
early version of the Marauders come
under the employ of sinister and go
about capturing various other individual
ual in addition we see the Marauders
taking the people that they have
currently captured back to the residence
of Nathaniel Essex down into a basement
laboratory that he's created and in this
basement laboratory he begins
experimenting on these mutants now we
don't know off the top of our heads or
at least it's not given to us whether or
not he's actually uh I guess physically
taking them apart physically examining
them that's more or less hinted to us in
the fact that Nathaniel essic says that
he's made great leaps in this
understanding of of the human genome so
that more or less tells us that he is
physically breaking down their bodies
that he's killing them and then
performing autopsies and examining them
and this is how Sinister functions for
quite some time but during this story
apocalypse is also awoken he's uh come
back out of his uh his suspended
animation and when he does he goes about
the process of examining the planet
Earth which is normal for Apocalypse
whenever apocalypse wakes up from a
slumber he examines the planet to see
whether or not it's the proper time for
him to invoke his IDE ideas of survival
of the fittest and attempt to take over
the world and when he gets to London he
of course meets Nathaniel Essex after
having killed a couple of the Marauders
and interrogated the last remaining
member and what this last remaining
member of the Marauders says is that
Nathaniel Essex is performing
experiments he's trying to understand
the concept of evolution in terms of
humans eventually becoming mutants and
so what apocalypse does is he under
takes a guise and meets Nathaniel Essex
he shape shifts and changes his form and
when he meets Nathaniel essics what
apocalypse realizes is that as far as he
understands he's the first step he's the
very first mutant which is Marvel coming
out and telling us that this is the case
this is Marvel telling us that
apocalypse is the first mutant to have
ever existed and so what apocalypse says
is that because he is the first mutant
that by his very existence he should be
the leader of all mutants forthwith and
so what he tells Sinister is to continue
his plans to continue his schemes of
course Sinister Amazed by the power that
apocalypse has but also Al using the
ulterior motive that because he's been
kicked out of the Royal Society and
shunned by virtually the entire
intellect of Britain as a whole that
he's going to need more powerful friends
and so with Apocalypse at his side he
begins experimenting again he begins
conducting his experiments and going
about trying to understand the genome
and the evolution of humanity now at the
same time there's also a couple other
things taking place of course the wife
of Nathaniel Essex is again become more
and more AR strange to him she is as she
explains still in love with him but
she's beginning to fear for what it is
that he's becoming now at the same time
we also see that Jean Gray and Scott
Summers are sent into the past and the
reason they're sent into the past is
because it is common knowledge in the
present timeline that Sinister had
become who he is as a result of genetic
manipulation at the hands of apocalypse
and so what's basically going on with
Jean Gray and Scott Summers is that
while they arrive in two different
locations in London they're One racing
to meet one another and two racing to
stop Nathaniel Essex from becoming a
henchman of Apocalypse but of course as
we know this ultimately fails now over
the course of this story as the comic
progresses we of course see that uh
Nathaniel Essex begins to give into the
more darker side of his nature that his
initial rationale of saying that science
is above any kind of decency or morality
stops being simple uh I guess talk and
becomes something that he actually
believes to the point that when his wife
leaves him after discovering that he had
dug up the body of their son and was
experimenting on him that she eventually
succumbs to an illness and when she does
she is dying and so Nathaniel Essex goes
to visit her but when she when he goes
to visit her she says that she doesn't
know who he is anymore that she doesn't
love him anymore and that he's truly
becomes something sinister which of
course results in Nathaniel Essex taking
the name Sinister once he is uh
genetically manipulated by apocalypse
and this is what we see with his
character as time progresses over the
course of this comic over the course of
the series we eventually learned that
with Nathaniel Essex his concern is that
there's just not enough time for him to
really understand the human genome
there's not enough time for him to
perform all his work and so after
creating a covenant or a pact with
apocalypse apocalypse manipulates the
genes of sinister and effectively makes
him Immortal which of course results in
Sinister being displayed to us with the
pale skin and and his normal physical
features now from here we transition to
Weapon X volume 1 issue number four 14
and what this does is it gives us this
in between period between the time that
Sinister had been experimenting on
mutants in the uh I guess the early
stages of mutants in the 19th century
all the way up until the current day now
it leaves out a few places in fact it
actually just picks up during World War
II but what we learned with Sinister is
that during this time when he was
manipulating the genes of individuals
that he was laying the foundation for
what would eventually become Weapon X
now this does doesn't mean that Sinister
had formed Weapon X what it means is
that Sinister going through his entire
existence manipulating the genes of
other individuals experimenting on
various individuals and so on and so
forth had his paperwork discovered when
he had abandoned the project and the
reason why is because Sinister had been
operating as the under the guise of
being a Nazi during World War II and
this allowed Sinister the ability to I
guess experiment on human beings without
any real regard or anyone questioning
his motivations because at the time in
Naz Nazi Germany it was common practice
for experiments to be performed on
anyone who was uh who was not a Nazi or
not a uh a previously established uh I
guess example of what a German should be
but when the Nazi camps were were
liberated when they were freed by the
Allied Forces Sinister had abandoned all
of his work and the work was discovered
by the initial Founders those
individuals who would eventually form
the weapon x project and using the work
that Sinister had previously done they
would go on to experiment on people like
uh like Maverick like Silver Fox and and
Sabertooth and wolver rain and
eventually lead us to the circumstance
whereby we have the weapon x project
that created the uh the character of uh
of of Wolverine now from here we're
going to go ahead and bring this video
to a close and the reason why is because
while Sinister exists so on and he moves
on forward and of course there's Miss
Sinister and things like that Sinister
is not really relevant here Sinister
appears from time to time but the
importance of his character had really
been established in the 1980s and 1990s
and then began to drop off to the point
where he was relegated to a background
character and he was never quite as
formidable of a villain as he had
previously been with that being said
we're going to go ahead and bring this
video to an end I hope you guys enjoyed
it if you did let me know and I will
catch you guys later
[Music]
peace
oh